hey what's up guys my name is samuel
leeds and right now we're standing in
arrow road warsaw which is where i grew
up as a kid with my parents sue and tim
and why are we standing here right now
why are we back in warsaw after he
became wealthy and moved out of warsaw a
couple years ago we saw this house and i
thought if this ever comes up for sale
we're buying it you wanted to buy this
house buy this house that's the thing
guys when you are a property developer
you just see properties where you think
oh that could have some added value so
the reason i wanted to buy this house is
because it'll be an ideal flip came on
the market recently bank came on the
market for 150 000 and you've just sold
it for 185 000 but not a lot of profit
so what tim what was it that made you
really want to buy this house there's
hidden land on it okay come on show us
the land what we've done is the house
was really run down right
it wasn't that bad though was it not
that bad
yeah ten thousand pounds doing it up
okay so you bought it for 150 you spent
10 grand you made one out five so you
made about 20 25 grand which to be
honest doesn't sound that exciting no so
what's the exciting part
the land so did you sell the house with
the land we've split the title right
this is it man
title splitting and getting played
permission we bought it obviously the
path used to come around here right onto
this drive here yes so now this is the
edge of that land yeah so we didn't want
the path here yeah so we've just changed
the path to there yeah because otherwise
if this person's not going to want the
path
no subjection here yeah we've put a gate
there put the new fence there yeah so
that's the new edge now to this land
right
how how much does it cost
to or how complicated is it because i
think a lot of people that are under the
impression that to title split yeah it's
like a big expensive scary process yeah
when you're selling this house yeah how
do you split it so that this doesn't
come with it quite easy actually you
just sell that
whatever you sell first gets onto a new
title
yes and the other one goes on the other
side so you just tell the slits does
don't include this show the drawers
yeah it's just literally a case of this
is what's included with the house this
is what's not yeah exactly simple so
title splitting is not doesn't have to
be really complicated so this land that
we're standing on right now
this now has planning permission what
have you got planning for exactly tim
three bed detached property three bed
detached property and you've now sold
the land off separate for how much 77.
which means all in all you made
approximately 100 000 pounds
absolutely incredible so how did you
know you were going to get planning for
this land and what was the planning
process like there was a garage right
came out to here we got that knocked off
was that part of the 10 grand refurb
yeah
peanuts so actually all this here yeah
have you already got a property on it so
so so you bought that you bought this
house and it came up here yeah not up to
there no just up to here yeah so all
that land yeah had a property on it
anyway so there's a little garage and a
utility and everything which we've
knocked off and was it a nice utility no
it's terrible right just a little
falling a little falling down with a
flat roof leaking removed really sold
that for one night five yeah so so
you've got planning for a three bed
detached house on here yeah and you
could why did you why did you choose not
to build yourself and then sell them in
new
the money's in the planning game not
build so you've created now
potentially
enough space for a whole nother house so
what so what you guys like to do is
profit from the planning
don't lift a shovel yeah well maybe a
hammer to knock it knock down but but
but just sell it with the planning so
you've sold this for 77 they'll build
their own little house might make a bit
of money but they'll have all the work
yeah involved with the build which
you've literally all you've done is got
put forward a planning application did
you put a pre-app in or did you just go
straight for full planning
straightforward and you were accepted
yeah how long did it take three months
bang so guys when you see a house like
this you might think oh i could buy and
rent it out like a few hundred quid a
month but you've just come in and out
made 100 grand bang next project amazing
let's have a look inside and you can
tell the story of how you found it
[Music]
okay so what was this like before
it was like this really but
rubbish carpet yeah um we've changed the
fire how much does it cost to get like
carpets in the whole house and with this
type of carpet about one and a half
grand for all the flooring and this is
well this looks quite different what
have you done here it was
an like an old-fashioned fire there yeah
but we've made a hole in the wall so
that goes in and how much did this cost
him
a hundred pounds
it doesn't cost that much does it to
sort of revolutionize an old ugly house
yeah exactly and of course for you this
was never the intention was never to
make money on this no as it happens you
did make a little bit of money on this
but you were always thinking about the
land we would have been happy just to
sell this
as it was for the price yeah yeah yeah
because you knew the profit was in the
planning this is nice so where did you
get this kitchen from
magnet a magnet kitchen and how much did
it cost
pounds for us is that okay is that just
for including all the you know the
tactics the whole lot the the um that
was the original from your kitchen
awesome i think one of the biggest
problems that people find with
properties at the moment trying to get
good deals
is that there's so many people snapping
up properties right now you bought this
from an estate agent yeah what was this
process i mean did you have people
trying to zump you what happened we saw
this on the market we really wanted it
phoned up the agent and the agent was
like
oh no we've had 10 people view it
already the landlord doesn't want any
more viewings at all and it was on the
market for 145. i knew we had to have it
because we've been waiting two years
yeah for it yeah so i was like well
can't we just have 11 viewings instead
of 10 viewers yes and she wouldn't let
us so i said well how about if we were
going to pay a lot more for it than the
asking house what if we were going to
pay a million pound
so then she went all right then we'll
let you have a viewing
but then i didn't really just leave it
to chance we contacted the owner
ourselves
um said we really liked it we were
willing to pay over the asking price so
when you contacted them did you just
come around put a letter through the
door the letter through the door yeah
next day he rang us up right um and we
paid five grand over the asking price
for it which is worth it 150 and you
bought it from bestow eaves yeah and
then i used to work for bestow around
here as well and then you've sold it
back with bestsellers
so from best there will even's point of
view the stat agent
developers and flippers are the best are
the best customers because they're gonna
get two sales yeah they're gonna sell it
to you and then they're gonna sell it
through you as well so nice great one
nice job in the kitchen
you fit this yourself right
right visit it okay a little bit of help
from me
yeah great good
nice
so for this whole project then i can see
it's been done pretty pretty nice what
happened in here then what did you have
to do in here plasterboarding yeah the
walls are in a bad state right the chips
of plaster is going to go off so i've
plastered board the whole of these walls
and how much does a piece of
plasterboard cost on one
put it there stuck it on painted it
carpets windows no
windows were already there so it's quite
a cheap reefer it looks a lot different
it looks a lot different you did it very
well to get it for 10 grand especially
considering that include the demolishing
of the garage and stuff
how much money in total did you need for
this entire project presumably you got a
mortgage
yeah so you bought it for 150 25 percent
37.5 was it and 10k on top of that so
about 47 grand yeah so you put 47 grand
in
and then you're pulling out you but you
get your 47 grand back plus 100 000
pounds profit that's incredible
absolutely
great it's the same sort of story in
here
did you have the pasta in here no we
just walloped this one yeah actually
it's got wallpaper on it still really it
was painted over the wallpaper and just
that was pink
we just painted that in a farrowing ball
yeah to make it look nice yeah it's
painted so this really is a lot of this
is just kitchen bathroom which you got
from magnet quite cheap carpets paint a
little bit of plasterboard i can see
even though it's a massive
transformation yeah it's not doesn't
cost that much to where it's expensive
is when you've got to start doing stuff
like rewiring new roof structural
problems
i want to talk about the planning aspect
because that's where the real profit is
in this house
how did you know you would get planning
and what would you have done if you
didn't get planning because exit
strategy is really important when you're
because you know when we buy a lot of
our properties or land we do it on an
option but this that wouldn't work for
this property would it because the guy
just wanted a straight sail yeah so talk
to me about exit strategies and stuff
okay so
when we bought this we didn't know we
were going to get planning right i'm not
sure but you thought you would we
thought we would because what we knocked
down was already a building yes so at
the end of the day you're replacing
building for building aren't you right
yeah so worst scenario we could have
just put another house joining onto it
so that was an exit strategy but we've
we haven't got that yeah also the land
was valued after we'd cut it off at 35
000. just straight without planning as
is at auction right so
obviously we've made a bit on this we
could have made 35 on that
so we could have made like 55 so even if
you haven't got planning if you just
still split the titles you could have
sold it without planning and made a bit
of money but as it happens you were
accepted and made made a very nice
packet what advice would you give to
somebody
wanting to develop small little things
like this and you know looking for
properties what are some of the things
to look out for and things to consider
okay
so we have to have a mining report on it
yeah because it's a mining area
um
really just
what's in the area so if you if you want
to stick something on the side and it's
not in keeping here it's literally in
film so as long as it's down there
houses over here yeah so
you don't want something that's not in
keeping yeah sometimes people bring to
me little pieces of land and they're
just isolated there's nothing around and
they think oh i get planning and it's
like well probably not um but yeah it's
following the patterns with this yeah
another one is um we tried to get two
houses on that land and we were turned
down yeah highways wouldn't allow it
right because too many cars and how does
it feel to have now got these sold i
know you're due to it uh complete
contract tomorrow yeah tomorrow i mean
how does it feel to have just come and
come out and made 100 very good we're
looking for another one yeah well you've
got multiple properties going on on the
go at the moment haven't you as well so
yeah really good job
so we spent 10 on it but to be honest we
had to draw the line somewhere yeah we
could have spent i mean we didn't we
could have done all that yes we've got
someone in just to cut the grass
but the grass is still not great and the
slabs and stuff and we put this fence up
obviously because that's the dividing
fence
but i looked at this fence and i thought
should we just paint this
in
keeping and i thought do you know what
that's going to make it look worse that
is right why would it make it worse it's
kind of just at the moment it's just
what it is concrete mixed but it would
have drawn attention to it then
and i think you'd have looked at it if
it had all been painted brown and it
would have just looked an ugly eye so
right and i think as well if you've got
all the front garden done and all the
you can spend a lot of money
in this area and for the type of house
price that we're talking it doesn't
really make sense the 80 20 rule isn't
it yeah exactly yeah so we drew the line
we could have easily spent 20 i reckon
yeah what been some of the big learning
points then for you in terms of not just
this project but just generally over the
years of doing property well as you know
i've started offering properties to buy
single nets and make a small increment
rent them out get them out
but you're not going to make a lot of
money doing that right 30 years
so now
buy some properties do them up sell them
yeah well yeah because how long would it
take to make a hundred grand if you were
just waiting for the rent a long time
probably 10 years 20 years because after
all the expenses
yeah but you've done all this you know
in the space of a year so great little
project ladies and gentlemen i hope you
enjoyed the video if you want to see
another project that my parents have
done on a little barn conversion where
they avoided stamp duty tax they avoided
capital gains tax and they avoided
income tax through capital allowances
you're going to learn a lot on that
video i'd suggest you check it out right
here also if you want to come along to
the property investors crash course and
learn how you can get into property
investment and property development
there's a link right here and don't
forget to subscribe and we will see you
next time
[Music]